[Music]
how often have you heard the phrase
age is just a number in esports
it can sometimes refer to some wily
whipper snapper who appears to be
skilled beyond their years from the
looks
out first he's had enough he's going to
keep going through it he doesn't really
care about his foreign
but in most competitive scenes it's used
ironically to describe
anyone over the age of 30 who continues
to prove
that they've still got it right now of
course he's just he's dueling them one
of the time he gets the headshot and
fallen
he might actually do this cold is behind
him oh my god he picks it up that's
gonna be the win
n.i.p what a way to start but in cs go
there's one group of truly weathered
mercenaries
who've given that expression a whole new
meaning
i'm talking of course about the
evergreen silver snipers
a lethal squadron of spirited pensioners
who will casually brain you on the
server
before taking their afternoon nap
a ragtag outfit of nearly ancient
cursor clickers who regularly
participate
in what is undoubtedly esports's
oldest rivalry oh that doesn't find the
bomb
it's long wrong way you'll
come park
there's the bomb but there's no more
time
and the pump goes down the swede stands
so how is it that this gang of
scrim-hardened ass-kicking elderlies
found themselves competing on one of
csgo's
biggest stages and aside from the
obviously charming
novelty of it all why exactly are they
doing it
now if you have not heard of the silver
snipers
boy are you in for a treat the team came
together
when several swedish thrill-seeking
geriatrics responded to an ad about
joining a senior
counter-strike team with the aim of
competing at
dreamhack summer 2018. now once the
early iteration of the roster was
assembled
it was time to put away the bingo cards
and get to work
and i get to work i obviously mean take
a
leisurely stroll to be you had a good
coach everybody of us
like to play but not so many
hours now before joining the team the
silver sniper's experience with video
games
generally was very limited but under the
tutelage of former pro player
tommy potty ingamarsen they eagerly
began to pick up the basics of
counter-strike
i was here many times everybody
was still and many times before
it's possible to win if you lose you can
teach yourself about your mistakes
and their efforts paid dividends with
the team
finding themselves comfortable enough to
compete in lan events by the end of 2017
and although silverware did evade their
grasp that year
the team was motivated enough by their
progress that they
ramped up their practice schedule and by
the spring of 2018
the silver snipers found themselves
competing for their first
trophy against an opponent that would
later become their greatest
rival finland's grey gunners
and it was in that grandpa final i mean
i mean grand finals
that the silver sniper showed everyone
just how deadly they could be
coming from the crosstalk time he
gets a nice nice heads up for the d
slayer but then
windy the team captain takes the round
for the swedes
fights finger
waiting on the side and gets down the
clutch 10
12.
the jerry tries to shoot through the
barrels
ah just a few pixels
to the right and trigger finger gets
down dirty hurry
after a thrilling two maps the silver
snipers emerged victorious
claiming their first senior cs title
and they were as excited as you can
imagine
[Applause]
now unfortunately for the silver snipers
the grey gunners would exact their
revenge at dreamhack summer 2018 but
in spite of falling short against their
finnish rivals
the lovable swedes really made a splash
in the scene
long after that event the team's lineup
went through a slight shuffleboard
sorry shuffle joining knitting knight
trigger finger
windy and die hard birdie was balthazar
el nino aguirre
who discovered his passion for cs go
through
playing with his son alongside their new
rifler
frederick jagarne anderson stepped in as
the team's coach
and with his support the snipers doubled
their efforts to challenge
yet again for another world championship
and by the time
dreamhack rolled around again in 2019
they had their chance once again the
snipers found themselves
facing off against their rivals the grey
gunners
in the grand finals the stage was set
the pressure was on
and the stakes were high and when these
two ancient juggernauts went at it
they gave fans what has to be the
greatest
spectacle in senior esports history
hey
this is weird
[Music]
so
counter terrorism
now as exciting as becoming the cs go
senior world champions
was for the silver snipers it's their
journey to
that moment that they truly hold dear
for the team's oldest member
die hard birdie counter-strike has
become more than just a hobby that he
indulges in for a few hours a day
it's become an opportunity for him to
bond with his family
i love playing with my dad and sometimes
my daughter gets involved so all three
of us play
my 12 year old daughter me and my dad
and while birdie has
officially stepped away from the
competitive scene like all
true esports retirees he's decided to
focus on growing his twitch channel
let's dance
as for the rest of the silver snipers
they continue to practice together
and show no signs of slowing down and
they've even begun fixing their sights
on zoomers so watch out i'll battle any
gamer
too scared kiss my own
look while it's very easy to write off
seniors gaming as a gimmick
it's really important to remember where
the idea for the silver snipers came
from
age can be the ultimate obstacle when it
comes to finding ways to
socialize with others loneliness and
depression are a
very real problem among seniors it's
easy for the older generation to feel
like the world has moved on without them
especially when they see their grandkids
glued to screens and seemingly getting
all the socializing they need from that
on top of the obvious social
and mental health benefits that gaming
offers
it's also been shown to improve focus
decision-making abilities
and problem-solving skills for those who
choose to spend their time
playing and for the silver snipers the
rush of defusing a bomb after clutching
a tight round
simply can't be beat you feel exciting
you feel blood pressure
you feel everything and sure it might be
difficult to get
graham and gramps to help you reach
global elite but
thanks to the silver snipers there's far
less reason to dismiss
the possibility of getting older
generations interested in esports
while most seniors are hesitant when it
comes to giving things like video games
a chance
these feisty fragging fogies have proven
that with some help from your loved ones
even learning to play a game as daunting
as cs go
is a challenge that can be overcome i
like to say
for the old people just find some guts
to wake up the spirits and ask
your children or grandchildren to help
you
this is very good for coordination
communication
between all generations and this dogged
determination and resilient competitive
spirit
is what makes rosters like the silver
snipers and grey gunners
trailblazing heroes not only are they
showing their fellow senior citizens
that they can
enjoy some of the things the modern age
has to offer but they found a way to
connect with a world that they
increasingly felt they weren't a part of
i mean i think this has been
really a life-changing experience for
them and
not only have they learned to love and
embrace technology
but i think they've also seen what
technology can do for them
and honestly as a future old person
how could you not love that
what about silver snipers that's not top
five i don't think we have a good top
five i think they would still dumpster
us
oh my literally three of them snipers
damn it if we took like four rounds off
these guys
i would be i would be impressed i'll be
honest we have zero utility with zero
all we can do is just hop out of palace
and just
line it straight for ct okay
no and then we're gonna go b let's go
what what you just killed our coach